President Biden's two visits one he's
been looking forward to the other he
sees no way around today Biden arrived
in Tel Aviv his first visit to Israel
since becoming U.S president it's a
visit the White House says would have
happened earlier had there been no
pandemic standing in the way later this
week Biden will travel on to Saudi
Arabia it's a visit that would probably
not be happening at all had there been
no war in Ukraine no inflation and no
skyrocketing fuel costs on the campaign
Trail two years ago Biden vowed to make
Saudi Arabia a pariah saying the salty
Crown Prince's role in the murder of
journalist Jamal khashoggi revealed a
kingdom lacking any redeeming values
President Biden's opinion it may or may
not have changed but the realities of
geopolitics certainly have Biden now
says he hopes to reorient not rupture
the U.S salty relationship in other
words he's hoping the Saudis agreed to
pump more oil onto the global market it
will be a delicate balancing act for the
U.S president making his visit to Israel
look more like a walk in the park
we have this report
it's not the first time Joe Biden is
visiting Israel but it is the first
since he became the president of the
United States
he is meeting with Israeli leaders to
strengthen ties that he says are already
firm
because the connection between the
Israeli people and the American people
is bone deep
it's bone deep
among the leaders was Israel's defense
minister who briefed Biden on the Iron
Dome the ion Dome is Israel's
state-of-the-art defense system to
intercept missiles Biden's dressed the
two Nations close cooperation on defense
projects
we're reaffirmed the unshakable
commitment of the United States to
Israel's security
including partnering with Israel on the
most cutting-edge defense systems in the
world
Biden then visited Yad vashem a memorial
for victims of the Holocaust
he lit an eternal flame of remembrance
and met survivors
the visit by a president of the United
States is always important because it
helps to amplify the voices of the
survivors it helps to amplify the plight
of the victims
Biden's visit comes at a time of
political turmoil in Israel and will
take him next to the West Bank
and then to a controversial stop in
Saudi Arabia
[Music]
so what is Joe Biden hoping to achieve
with this trip to Israel I put that
question to our correspondent Rebecca
Ritter's in Jerusalem
well I don't think there's going to be
any major
prizes It is believed from here Brent
but it is of course very significant
It's always important when the U.S
president comes to Israel he's hoping to
strengthen those already bone deep ties
as he said himself that's something that
the you know the special relationship
between the US and Israel something that
the US are always very keen to you know
show their support for but he's also
trying to uh sort of shore up stability
a little bit in the region you know try
and find some more peace and Security in
the region than perhaps in previous
years and try and maybe smooth the way
it seems for a regional peace Alliance
that would counter threats from Iran so
in that sense he's here to kind of
negotiate between two sides who've been
foes for many years uh and try and
arrange for some yeah Regional Alliance
as I say a defense alliance between
those two states and we knew that his
next stop is the Palestinian territories
talk to me about how unusual it is for a
U.S president to go there
not to meet with Mahmoud Abbas pretty
much every U.S prime minister sends Bill
Clinton in 1994 first met with the
Palestinian Authority has done so when
they come to Israel with a few
exceptions largely for for diary issues
or something else so really it is a
pretty standard operating procedure the
visit on Friday is only half an hour so
the Palestinians quite disappointed that
you know the president is spending two
days in Israel just half an hour with
the Palestinians but of course uh you
know they they're happy to greet the
president of course and with it with
that visit is coming a promise of more
funding and opening up of more funding
towards the Palestinians that were that
were cut under the Trump Administration
so but definitely sort of an unweighted
uh visit and something that is not not
going unnoticed by the Palestinians and
it will we could say probably be one of
the the more easier parts of his trip
his final stop we understand is going to
be Saudi Arabia and that is going to be
the most controversial part of the
president's trip why is that
it's it's of course Very controversial
not least of all because of Saudi
Arabia's uh human rights record
questionable human rights record one
could say uh you know President Joe
Biden himself called Saudi Arabia Pariah
State and also referencing the Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman there saying
to do with their dealings whether that
their alleged
um
role in The Killing of journalist Jamal
khashodky so this is a 180 turnaround by
the president but it comes at a time
when Russia has invaded Ukraine and
you're seeing uh you know oil prices
rise across the globe that's something
that he's trying to take home
domestically to lower the price at the
Bowser for people in the U.S to try and
make this trip more popular domestically
and of course ahead of you uh the
midterms that come November
that was our correspondent Rebecca
readers there reporting from Jerusalem
all right I want to take this now to
trita Parsi he's Executive Vice
President at the Quincy Institute for
responsible statecraft Trina is
considered one of the leading voices on
U.S policy in the Middle East Trent it's
good to see you again I understand that
earlier thank you for having me earlier
today you were part of a panel
discussion entitled Biden's trip to the
Middle East bad deal or shrewd diplomacy
so which is it
well if I was the moderator and
according to the panelists it was
clearly a bad deal if there will be a
deal at all the most likely scenario
perhaps may be that there won't be
anything at all in the sense that there
will be a lot of empty rhetoric a lot of
photo ops but in terms of actually
signed agreements particularly the thing
that the emiratis and the Saudis wants
which is a written Defense Act between
them and the United States in which the
US would commit itself to defend these
dictatorships it does not appear to be
very very likely so the question is will
it only be these type of uh photo ops or
will there actually be some substance
ability yeah because I was expecting
Iran and defense policy to be the two
elements that Biden would be able to
address in both Israel and Saudi Arabia
maybe the glue holding this trip
together
oh it certainly is the glue from the
perspective of the Saudis and the
Israelis this is not only a threat
perception that they have but it's also
a threat perception that needs to remain
in place if you want to see this warm-up
of relations between the Saudis and uh
the Israelis but that in and of itself
however uh creating a defense act around
that is not something that necessarily
will stabilize the region and it's also
not something that necessarily would be
helpful to the United States in fact
what Tony blinken himself wrote In The
New York Times in 2017 When Donald Trump
was pursuing this path and was seeking
together with the Saudis to create
essentially an anti-iran Coalition he
wrote In The New York Times that the
anti-shia Coalition masquerading as a
peace agreement or a defense uh pact is
a bad idea because it will intensify in
the region and potentially drag the
United States in it it would have been
much better he wrote for the United
States not to take sides but instead
pressure all of these different parties
to seize some of their destabilizing
activities it's good advice in my view
it's advice I think Joe Biden should
take Intruder other than paying lip
service to a possible two-state solution
between Israelis and the Palestinians
this trip is not going to do anything to
move the needle is it
it's a trip that is not even designed to
move the needle it's probably not even
designed to provide much lift service
either because an expansion of the
Abrams report which is essentially that
we set aside this Palestinian issue and
and move forward with normalization
between Arab states and Israel was
explicit that this is not about
resolving it it's about moving beyond
the israeli-palestinian conflict to have
normalization and trade even though the
Israelis continue to occupy uh
Palestinian territories and keep
millions of Palestinians under
occupation so we should have no
expectation that it will move the needle
because it does not even have that
ambition and let me before I let you go
let me bring up Saudi Arabia one more
time from Pariah now to partner what
does President Biden have to do here
other than avoid a photo op with him
shaking the hand of the salty Crown
Prince
well I'll be very Frank I don't think uh
President Biden is gonna get much out of
this alley I don't think there's going
to be much oil production that will have
an impact on all prices in fact if all
prices is the driving force of this then
buy them would have been better off
going back into the Iran Mutual deal and
bringing ivaninol to the market because
there's more Spirit capacity there and
also a very large reserve of oil that is
just sitting in Iran so I'm not so sure
that oil prices really is uh the driving
force here but uh my point being that
unless the Saudis feel that they either
get something that students rehabilitate
MBS meaning a handshake or if they uh
our unless they get some security
assurances I'm not so sure that they
will give anything to buy
well tridi let me just ask you before we
run out of time then the the Iran
nuclear deal if I'm hearing you
correctly I mean chances for Reviving
that deal are about as good as zero
right now
yes and I think frankly further uh
reduce as a result of this trip because
the idea that you can have a jcpoa a raw
nuclear deal that stops nuclearization
on Yvonne essentially disarms or
prevents the Iranians from having that
Armament while at the same time building
an anti-evonne military Coalition you
might guess a deal but you will ensure
that it will not last because that's not
what you need in order to make sure that
heat agreement will be lasting and
durable this is the opposite of that so
it leaves me with the impression that
the abide Administration has by now
completely given up on even having that
ambition
Executive Vice President at the Quincy
Institute for responsible statecraft
trid as always good talking with you we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
thank you so much for having me
appreciate it
Dr Melanie Garson she's an expert on
conflict resolution at University
College London she joins me tonight from
Tel Aviv it's good to have you with us
the situation in the Middle East has
dramatically shifted since Joe Biden
visited the area last which was six
years ago
how has that changed U.S policy
time for the U.S to revisit an
understanding of
how much the Middle East has shifted so
a recent survey that's going to the
report for which it's going to be
released tomorrow by the time Blair
Institute actually shows a radical
change across five countries key
countries in the Middle East with sort
of 72 percent support for Saudi Arabia's
wide range reforms and reducing the
power of religious authorities and
liberalizing societies and economic
diversification and I think this is
going to lead to a shift once uh
President Biden begins to feel the
ground truth
um in the Middle East and how that will
then realign U.S policy a little bit
well this should be music to the ears of
the bind Administration though right I
mean these sound like positive changes
in public opinion that you're describing
but interestingly enough as a report
detail says a the parallel polling in
across Western Nations actually shows a
great misunderstanding with the
assumption that actually
um the whereas only 46 percent of the
West believe that the Middle East is
um friendly the 72 percent of the Middle
East see the West as partners so yes it
should be music to is but I think
there's a lot that has been going on
particularly in a very polarized U.S
that has distorted the reality on the
ground and how fast the Middle East is
moving into a place that is potentially
a more positive Ally for the United
States and would you say that the
nuclear threat posed by Iran is that the
main reason we are seeing a shift in
security cooperation
uh the Iranian threat has definitely
been a galvanizing Force particularly
between Israel and countries within the
gulf I think there's also wider
cooperation I think the it's not just
the nuclear threat of Iran I think it's
the wider nature of how threats can
operate in highly connected uh system so
particularly thinking of how many of the
countries across the gulf are connected
to the internet of things that Iran is
not only a nuclear threat but an
increasing cyber threat and that
threatens Supply chains of food security
of Health Tech and in that very wide
conception of what security is today uh
in the Middle East then we're going to
see a real galvanizing of the partners
particularly in the relationship with
Israel with its Tech advantages and you
know you talk about these these changes
and yet here we are with the Israelis
and the Palestinians the President
visiting and yet we know that the two
State solution is not a reality in the
near future for either side right
the the general consensus is that the
ripeness in timing that would be
required for both parties to sit down
and really have a productive set of
talks that can be delivered at home to
their home constituency to their own
people is not quite there yet having
said that I think this is a particularly
important step forward for President
Biden to be here to be able to the
process of being put on hold for a long
time that's a series of trust and
confidence building measures by
traditionally uh the Israeli governments
haven't held much stuck in the sort of
the democratic narrative that's been
coming out around the peace process the
Palestinians have felt equally put to
the side in the wake of a lot of the
advances in the Middle East so I think
as an initial step this is an important
building block to perhaps moving forward
and I the I believe is that President
Biden will release news about an
increased past
a package of Aid that he will be
visiting Palestinian hospital and the
first meeting with uh president Abbas is
also a big step forward yeah and doing a
lot of what the Trump Administration did
in its four years Dr Melanie Garson
joining us tonight from Tel Aviv Dr
Carson we appreciate your time and your
insights thank you